hey guys welcome back and today is
Tuesday so that means the Ubisoft
developers had their weekly Warriors den
development stream now if none of you
guys know what this is it basically it's
all the Ubisoft developers like three or
four of them they get together they talk
about the issues of the game or stuff
they're planning on doing in the next
week or two and sometimes they get asked
questions by the fans are the person
interviewing them and then they tend to
fight some of the people during the
stream or some high-level players just
with some casual fun now this recap or
this dead stream wasn't exactly the most
exciting but there was a lot of
interesting points made toward the end
of the stream Nick one of these kind of
really pissed me off Bo understand so
one of the problems I was noticing is
that these developers are super vague
and they start to dodge a lot of the
important questions which will start to
understand and like about a couple the
second tier but it's just I don't
understand whether will give us a full
answer we're kind of give us a vague
answer completely shy away just doesn't
really make a lot of sense no I don't
know if any of you have seen this but
recently there's been a post of some
website talking about if you were to get
every item in for honor without paying
any steel or by paying first do I should
say it would cost you around seven
hundred dollars worth of your money to
buy everything in the game and if you
weren't to do that and you were just to
grind it out the they calculated to be
about two and a half years or about two
years to get every item for every
character in the game which is a lot
like it's really stupid to some people
because not everybody has their main
that they you know that they play as and
that's it some people have like two or
three then there's the few really try
hard players that have like every
characters their favorite and they want
to get every item to completionist
you've probably heard of them of those
there's a bunch of people that do
completion is stuff for every game I
want to be surprised if there's one for
this game too but they talked about the
issue being there's it's basically seven
hundred dollars to get every emote
execution effect etc and the response
was you were meant to played every
character in the game or get every item
that's not what they intended it to be
so that every completionist that was
hitting every item in the game
have fun because the devs never intended
for any of that to happen they also
wanted people to spend their steel
because I guess a ton of people have
capsular steel because you know they
have like one or two characters so they
ended up that's why they came out with
these new emotes and executions that
they can have people to spend their
steel instead of keeping it and they
said that they said that like this is
their main issue yes this is their main
issue over the connection problem all of
you have experienced that if you've
played for honor at least about 10
minutes you've experienced that the
dispute issue they have where players
aren't spending anything is their main
issue over the connection the baffles my
[ __ ] mind who thought of that now the
bad stuff aside we got some good things
coming toward the beginning of the
season all there's going to be new gear
for all characters and new in two new
maps two to three new maps so after the
season's over this season is over at the
very beginning we're going to get some
new items a new gear looks great
competitive will be coming after the
connections fixed so we might be here a
while spectator mode is going to be in
the works which is a good thing because
if you've ever seen any local
tournaments of any of you vent on the
foreign or subreddit for the competitive
or on our subreddit which you can all
check out there great places to be if
you want to get caught up on for honor
stuff so I get most of my information
from they have these like daily weekly
tournaments going on hosted on stream
usually now the problem with these
streams that if it's a 1v1 duel they
actually have three people the one per
it's basically a 2v1 but one of the
person that person is the twitch
streamer who is the host we're basically
one player versus the other player and
then one of them is on that their team
and then the opposite player has to kill
that guy that he has to spectate his
teammate in order for it to count as a
match because there's no spectator mode
so it's the next best thing it's super
it just doesn't look right it looks
unprofessional it's not the way it's
supposed to be done so I'm glad they're
having the spectator mode and plus e if
you've ever watched on in this
tournament you always get the one player
perspective what if you want to see the
other guys perspective we can't do that
so it's kind of hard to do all this some
either very late they're working on the
spectator mode because I've loved
watching these tournaments these
high-level players it's so much fun
watching this the next thing they're
going to be doing is getting reworks on
Raider and Berserker a little bit on
logging or two but it's mostly Raider in
Berserker I don't want I kind of
understand Raider but I never really
understood the point of the zerker being
on this list he seems completely fine
with me any beserker players that play
him you can maybe give me some insight
on what's wrong because I don't really
see anything honestly he seems perfectly
normal roads I mean maybe a bit too oaky
but that's just my taste they're going
to be fixing the gear stats they also
believe that revenge mode is not working
as it as is intended no [ __ ] you got the
person that's Brett ten orochi gets hit
twice guard breaks or guard break
someone or blocks two attacks and he's
already got revenge mode like what is
that [ __ ] so I'm go ahead they
notice this a little bit too late I mean
should have probably recognize this as
like the first week of the game but as
long as they notice it I'm okay our
personal opinion on this though it
sounds like I'm like talking [ __ ] like
mad [ __ ] against the debs here I don't
mean to sound that way I'm just a little
bit frustrated with the steel portion
because I don't play every character but
I have like maybe three to four
characters i play as which is can say
law bring or the occasional Valkyrie and
then if I want to switch it up a warden
or even shugo be like if I want to get
all the good stuff of the characters and
look nice and have all this great stuff
that makes this game more fun and more
playable for me I'm going to be a
sitting on my ass hole they put in 15
hours a day just to get this stuff and
then as the as all these servers start
you know breaking and crashing and [ __ ]
then it's like it's even less time I
have to get all the items so what's the
point there they really need to dumb
down the steel count at least ounce at
least in the near future because this is
aggravating a very a multitude of
players it might get to the point where
people are going to start leaving and
then it's going to be too late for
Ubisoft even fix it cuz 34 so the player
base is gone only a small portion of the
people are playing and
it's just basically a dead game and
nobody wants that in the game that they
like especially for on I love this game
I love doing videos on it love
entertaining you guys with it it's just
annoying because then it's half the
playerbase goes down that means not as
many people are going to be watching the
videos I'm not going to have a lot of
fun cuz I'm going to get put with all d
trihard players that still play the game
and she's not going to be an overall fun
thing for everyone play I hope you guys
did enjoy the song going to start doing
this more weekly since these do come out
weekly on every tuesday i'm going to
start doing some recaps here i hope you
all did enjoyed this video I want to
hear all your opinions on this weekly
dev recaps and what you think should
have been changed we think they should
added any any any sauce at all on this
would be greatly appreciated I hope you
guys did enjoy though I like the video
if you did dislike it if you didn't like
it if you're new to this channel hit
that subscribe button we do in the
weekly dev stream every week then we
also going to be doing additional four
on our content on the side just just
take a look at my most recent videos you
understand what the channels about I
don't be able to enjoy though and a
peace out guys I hope you all have a
great rest of your day